celebrities love endorsing presidents
and presidents love celebrity
endorsements and this is the story of
the president that started it all
warren harding was the 29th president of
the united states before that harding
was a pretty generic senator the new
york times even dubbed him faint and
colorless so how the hell did he win the
presidency
three words florence kling harding his
wife and shrewd campaigner
florence had her ear to the ground
anytime a famous or influential person
came to town she would have them pose
for a photo on their front porch so
basically the first political selfie
enter al jolson
at the time deemed the world's greatest
entertainer
he sang he danced he even landed the
first talking role in a movie most
importantly he became the first
celebrity to ever endorse a presidential
candidate
harding had several other celebrity
endorsements most notably thomas edison
and henry ford and guess what it worked
warren harding became our 29th president
and despite going down as one of the
worst presidents in u.s history his
political selfies changed the landscape
forever